So there's a fairly well established procedure for cleaning
data. Now, the specifics are going to very from one
situation to another, but the overall process remains the
same. Here, we're going to go through this blueprint, or procedure.
And then immediately following this discussion, we'll look at
a concrete example following this blueprint. So, the first step
is to audit your data. Now, in this step
what you'll be doing is programatically checking the data using
some validation rules you've written, and you'll create a
report on the quality of the data. Now, you
might also want to run a statistical analysis in
order to, for example. check for outliers. Having run your
audit, then you use that information to create a
data cleaning plan. In our data cleaning plan, we
want to identify any causes of the dirty data
that we're seeing. Now, this is going to be very situation-specific.
Then we're going to define a set of operations that
will correct our data, again, situation-specific. And finally what you
want to do, is run a few tests to make sure
that your data cleaning plan is going to do what you need
it to do. Next we're going to execute the plan.
Now just to be clear, this is essentially running a script
that will execute that set of operations you defined in
the data cleaning plan. Now it's possible, in fact it's likely,
that we won't have been able to programatically clean our
data entirely. And if it's necessary for you to do
so, there maybe a manual correction step, where you go
through, or you hire someone to go through, and make
any changes that need a human eye in order to
correct the data. Now, again this is another process where
we have humans involved, so once we've gone through all
this, it makes a lot of sense, in my opinion,
to iterate on this, possibly more than two
iterations, until you have confidence in your data.